audiences love when on screen romances
get steamy but behind the scenes it's
not always the stuff of dreams whether
it was due to bad acting weird memories
or embarrassing injuries here are some
love scenes that actors wish they could
take back Jennifer Lawrence has had
multiple romantic scenes with some of
Hollywood's dreamiest leading men but it
wasn't until the 2016 sci-fi drama
passengers that one of her love scenes
went beyond kissing she had to get cozy
with her handsome co-star Chris Pratt
but she wasn't entirely comfortable with
the premise as she told The Hollywood
Reporter it was really bizarre it was
really weird everything was done right
it wasn't anybody's fault
nobody did anything wrong it's just a
bizarre experience her discomfort
stemmed from guilt over the fact that
Pratt was married at the time to actress
Anna Faris as Lawrence noted it was
going to be my first time even kissing a
married man and guilt is like the worst
feeling in your stomach I knew it was my
job but I couldn't tell my stomach the
scene came back to haunt Lawrence again
months after passengers left theaters in
August 2017 Pratt and Ferris announced
that they were separating and unfounded
rumors started spreading that Lawrence
was somehow involved she called it the
weirdest rumor she'd heard about herself
fortunately Faris took the high road
writing in her memoir unqualified that
she and Lawrence are on friendly terms
the James Bond franchise is famous for
its steamy scenes between agent
double-oh-seven
and an unending array of stunningly
beautiful women but things don't always
go smoothly backstage 1985's a view to a
kill was the last of Roger Moore's six
Bond films he was 57 at the time of the
film's release making him the oldest
actor to ever play the role but the
women bond seduces stay eternally young
one of his conquests in the film Mayday
was played by model and musician Grace
Jones who was 20 years Moore's junior
and boy did their age gap create some
tension on set in his memoir Moore
remembered that Jones would play loud
music in her dressing room which
prevented him from getting his afternoon
nap
after unsuccessfully asking her to turn
the music down
he got so annoyed that he threw a chair
at the dressing-room wall as he dryly
observed this didn't help set the mood
for their upcoming love scene
fortunately Jones didn't hold Moore's
outburst against him forever after his
death in 2017 she described him as quote
a great gentleman and declared he will
always remain one of my best experiences
in my filming career there are probably
a lot of moments that the actors in the
notorious so bad it's good movie the
room regret filming Juliet Danielle
plays Lisa brought up one moment in
particular during a reddit AMA when she
first saw one of the movies famously
long love making scenes she was quote
mortified unbeknownst to her a
rose-petal had stuck to her back and on
the big screen it looks a lot like a
scab and that's not exactly something
you'd want to show off to a theater full
of strangers another movie director
might have used a different shot to
spare his actress the embarrassment but
not the eccentric Tommy Wise Oh Danielle
admitted that shooting the erotic scenes
were uncomfortable but quotes pretty
standard but then she elaborated the
only difference is that Tommy used all
the footage rather than whittling it
down to a short sequence like most do
Danielle's not sorry that she appeared
in an infamously bad movie as it's led
to other opportunities and she's come to
terms with being Lisa from the room
forever but she does regret that she
appeared in it without her clothes on
yeah Tammy part Lisa sometimes when
actors get caught up in steamy moments
it leads to painful results during a
2016 episode of Jimmy Kimmel Live how to
get away with murders Viola Davis
admitted that she and co-star Billy
Brown had taken their direction for a
love scene a bit too far Brown was told
to seductively slam Davis up against a
wall and she was up for it so she pulled
out all the stops
but then she proceeded to throw her back
out the injury was bad enough that Davis
put a temporary hold on the especially
intense love scenes
she also joked with Kimmel that she kept
the slightly awkward injury a secret
from her husband
Julius tennen who's also an actor
tenon appeared in one episode of how to
get away with murder and he even had his
own love scene with his wife that
resulted in a different kind of mishap
as it happened Davis felt so safe and
comfortable acting opposite her husband
that she got a little distracted he had
to take my panties off at one point I
said and then I had to keep resetting
them because you know you got to keep
doing the scene over and over again when
you're on a show called Sex in the City
you know you're gonna be spending a
healthy portion of your time faking
passion Kristin Davis who played prim
and proper Charlotte was usually fine
with her characters exploits but not all
the time during a 20-19 appearance on
watch what happens live she told Andy
Cohen about the one love scene she
really hated in a season 3 episode
Charlotte goes to bed with investment
banker Alexandre Laemmle a gentleman in
the streets and a foul-mouthed shouter
in the sheets Christopher or the actor
who played Laemmle had to yell certain
derogatory words in her face during the
scenes climax which Davis admitted she
didn't enjoy one bit and that wasn't the
only time the actress had her struggles
on the proudly raunchy show in
particular there was one scene involving
self-love Davis recalled I wanted to do
it but I was scared my heart was
pounding
I had adrenaline like crazy on the
bright side Davis is at least able to
take solace in the fact that Charlotte
was nowhere near as shocking as her
co-star Kim Cottrell's performance as
the lascivious Samantha considering that
the American Pie flicks are all about
teenagers humiliating themselves while
trying to satisfy their hormonal urges
you could understand if its actors would
want to disavow them but Jason Biggs who
played the PI loving Jim has said that
he doesn't regret the whole thing though
there is one scene he takes issue with
in that particular sequence Jim sets up
a webcam to record his classmate Nadia
while she's alone in his bed
she changes into her underwear and sets
about satisfying her urges by herself
Jim eventually walks back in and joins
her which leads to one of the most
famous moments of humiliation ever
caught on film
the problem for bigs isn't any
embarrassment he had while filming it
but rather how the scene doesn't really
stand the test of time in 2020 he told
BuzzFeed it wouldn't get made now and it
couldn't get made now it would be
unacceptable what that represents the
conversation now is totally different
now to what it was 20 plus years ago so
the art that's made surrounding it needs
to be totally different Shannon
Elizabeth who played Nadia agrees in
2019 she told page six that she's
grateful to be remembered for the role
but she also noted if this had come out
after the hashtag me - movement there
would definitely be a problem I think
that it would have gone down differently
etiquette can make or break an acting
partnership just ask miles teller in
2013 he starred opposite shailene
woodley in the teen romantic drama the
spectacular now the couple smooching
scenes earned them a nomination for Best
Kiss at the MTV Movie Awards but it
required a lot of acting on tellers part
to make it look like he was enjoying one
of those kisses before their first
lip-lock Woodley swallowed quote Chinese
dirt supplements according to teller
they tasted exactly how they sound but
while he may not have enjoyed the
kissing at least he apparently got along
with Woodley otherwise the pair went on
to star together in the divergent
trilogy and were often pictured hanging
out with each other at fancy Hollywood
events in his 2014 Vanity Fair profile
of Woodley teller was quoted as saying
she's just like a positive energy force
that's very infectious wickley has
compared their relationship to other
famous platonic friendships like those
between Kate Winslet and Leonardo
DiCaprio and Julia Roberts and George
Clooney but despite their closeness they
probably won't be locking lips again any
time soon
guys we're built to survive Salma Hayek
fought for years to tell Mexican painter
Frida Kahlo story on the big screen
so she was overjoyed when Harvey
Weinstein's studio Miramax agreed to
fund the project with
starring and producing but the
experience was far from a happy one in a
20-17 New York Times op-ed hyatt claims
that weinstein harassed her and became
enraged when she turned down his
advances after it became clear that she
wouldn't give in to his demands he tried
to destroy her movie I knew it was a
challenge that was given to me so that I
would fail according to Hayek Weinstein
told her five weeks into filming Freda
that she had to appear in a love scene
with another actress or he would cancel
the film Hayek felt that she had
exhausted all other options so she shot
the scene but it took a mental toll on
her on the day of shooting she had what
she describes as a nervous breakdown as
she put it my body began to shake
uncontrollably my breath was short and I
began to cry and cry unable to stop as
if I were throwing up tears the problem
wasn't that she was uncomfortable being
intimate with another woman it was that
she felt forced into it
a spokesperson for Weinstein denied
Hayek's version of events but this was
far from the only allegation of this
nature he's been accused of Anna
Kendrick is known for speaking her mind
and she doesn't hold back when she's
talking about love scenes with her
co-stars except when it comes to naming
names in her memoir scrappy little
nobody
Kendrick admitted that sometimes how she
feels about her cast mates affects her
enthusiasm for intimate scenes for
example she once argued with a director
over kissing an actor who was playing
her boyfriend as she put it I felt like
there was simply no motivation for them
to kiss in that moment the director
explained that they were meant to be a
happy couple which involved kissing so
they kissed but Kendrick wasn't happy
about it
as for what co-star she's talking about
there are at least two who can be ruled
out she's described kissing Chris Pine
and into the woods as quote cinnamon
meadow and she has no regrets over the
smooch she shared with Blake Lively in a
simple favor though it did require some
choreography between the two actresses
as she told pride source
I remember Blake and I both feeling like
neither of us wanted to be the aggressor
we definitely struggled to find that
perfect balance of there's just this
moment and they both get caught up in it
and it's a little uncomfortable the
first time that many American movie
goers met Margot Robbie was in 2013's
white collar crime flick the wolf of
Wall Street the film required her to
perform several love scenes with
Leonardo DiCaprio but there was one that
left a mark literally as it involved
rolling around in piles of fake money as
she explained to the Daily Beast I got a
million paper cuts on my back from all
that money then the crew told her you
look like you've been whipped a million
times your back is covered in a thousand
red scratches there was another love
scene that posed some different
challenges it takes place in a nursery
and while shooting it Robbie had to
perform er moves and lines in front of
an all-male crew for 17 hours in a very
cramped bedroom
she told meta potay it's just a very
weird thing and you have to bury the
embarrassment and absurdity really deep
and fully commit just stay away from
that fake money check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]